m
dans le cadre du 350e anniversaire du
peuplement de l'île
soixante quinze collégiens ont eu la
chance de voyager en inde en chine et en
bretagne afin de marcher sur les traces
de leurs ancêtres au delà de l'aventuré
des expériences inoubliables
l'autre temps fort et la restitution des
carnets de voyages réalisés avec la bd r
un rendez vous festif organisé à
l'espace rédelé avec divers animations
musicales et ateliers lithiques parents
enfants professeurs et principaux de
collège avait répondu présent à
l'invitation du conseil départemental
est donc aujourd'hui on est au moment de
la restitution on découpe ses carnets de
voyage
les parents découvrent les carnets que
leurs enfants réalisé et c'est
formidable parce que souvent on oublie
ça s'est passé il ya deux mois trois
mois six mois un an et puis le fait
d'avoir collé des choses d'avoir ramené
des photos des textes
il ya des choses extraordinaires il ya
des cure dents il ya les les caches dieu
qu'on met dans l'avion fait ils ont tout
collé tout était prétexte à raconter ce
voyage est donc pas aujourd'hui ce
carnet c'est vraiment un moyen
d'échanger avec les autres sur ce voyage
les soixante quinze collégiens de
montgaillard de jean days mais de la
montagne ont présenté à leurs camarades
leur destination
ils ont partagé leurs émotions leur
ressenti sur la découverte de ces pays
des coteaux de l'arrêt au port les
billets dans l'avion et le jour du
départ
à aix était en fait la suivante un
chemin
ça la fout
on a touché quasiment toujours de maux
que ce potage mois
à travers ses voyages les collégiens ont
pu découvrir les pays d'où sont issus
les peuples qui ont façonné la
population réunionnaise
il est nécessaire de savoir d'où l'on
vient pour bâtir son avenir
ainsi c'est une page de notre histoire
que ces soixante quinze collégiens ont
pu découvrir alors on était partis donc
on avait travaillé sur les engagés qui
était devenu à la fin de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé travailler sur dans les
champs de canne à la réunion comment il
avait emmené avec eux la culture bon
pour résumer les temps plein le cabri
massalé les épices etc
on avait travaillé là dessus et pour
nous on faisait un peu le chemin inverse
d'aller vers ces gens là mais pas
seulement vers ces gens là mais aussi
bien la beauté glane des parents
enchantés de découvrir les carnets de
leurs enfants un véritable récit de leur
voyage accompagnés de photographies de
dessins ou encore d'objets abbas et les
souvenirs cd souvenir énorme pour lui
surtout à
1 quand je lui ai dit nous peut-être moi
je vais pas y aller mais lui quand même
il a pu voir que moi je verrais pas en
quoi c'est tout ce que je lui ai dit le
bouddha c'est un truc que j'adore
donc il a découvert les temples
l'inculture etienne à il a pris quand
même pas mal de choses
voilà valorisation du partage
d'expériences enrichissement ouverture
culturelle sur le monde
tels sont les principaux objectifs de
ces voyages de découverte grâce à ce
dispositif le conseil départemental fait
voyager chaque année environ 50 classes
soit près de 1500 élèves